eric antoine magic day au ralenti dans
toute la france alors vous êtes vous
attendez plus grand magicien eric
antoine mois par la taille
non mais je vais vous montrer j'ai pris
quelques cours de magie parce que je
suis fasciné par la magie et je vais
vous faire un tour de magie ce soir je
vais choisir quelqu'un dans le public et
je vais la télé portée oui au hasard
complètement je vais prendre la première
personne qui me tombe sous la main
baky qui qui envient voilà ici
hydraulique qui vous vous non on peut
pas vous vous venez pas venir je vais
porter ses regards d assurer une
expérience unique au monde
vous saviez pas qu'il y avait des
talents de magicien un déballage peux
vous dire vous allez avoir le cul
concassé joue dit vous ne risquez rien
d'accord d'accord géomètre dans cette
cabine et je vais vous téléporter les
jeunes nom de dieu c'était quand même le
seul magicien qui les tâches des faux
niveau des trucs mauvaise idée pour un
autre tour attention au wat trois
garnements des arénas sont connus
[Rires]
j'avais vu la jeune fille qui était
là-bas dans la cabine et bien cette
jeune fille j'ai réussi à la jerry
porter regarder la cabine à la pas
bouger pour aller voir derrière j'ai
vérifié de tétouan des papiers à toi y'a
pas que le public n'avait pas vu passer
là-bas et bien cette personne est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mode est bien c'est de faire ça
regardez bien ces personnes je retourner
là bas et je répare faire face les
regarder non mais c'est grillé qui est
retombé ces courbes et moi on se révolte
vous est un essai
je suis un homme à aller taux d'intérêt
les plus bas
la cabine ouvrait logiquement tout l'été
les porter ça fait le christ a tenu à
faire ensemble
non ça va non mais vous est ce que vous
pouvez faire ou pas moi je peux faire
disparaître et ça regarde et je vais moi
je vais télé pour te garder votre hills
à regarder leur antre message tu deviens
à haute dose
regardez bien il ça il sort est là et
bien regardez ici et là bas
[Applaudissements]
elles selon l'humeur
est-ce que vous avez un pourra nous
faire moi avait-il alors explosé on
n'est pas complice tu le jura non je
vous jure bas côté droit vers la côte
est la maintien auquel est sur la
première page de ce carnet il ya le nom
d'une carte iata carte la carte rethel
tu vas pensé du jeu qu'on n'ait pas
compris ça je vous le jure d'accord si
tu mens tu aurais aimé des gens il faut
pas confiance en moi tu peux pas prendre
quelqu'un d'autre avec kenora on attend
ce que tu veux celui en qui on papa jean
michel mr forcément apprendra pas vite
vite
mais revoilà vita à les jurés que nous
ne sommes pas complices vous le jurer
cela revient cher surmonter en enfer
d'accord mais d'accord vous ne croyez
pas l'enfer j'imagine finissez votre
promotion chez patrick sébastien
on a l'accord et on est bon très bien il
ya une carte sur ce carnet une et une
seule
j'aimerais vous pensiez une carte et la
carte laquelle vous pensez vita c'est le
critère dit à quelqu'un pensez vous une
carte des dangers
qu'avez vous dit à une carte bleue l'as
de carreau si ici écrit ta carte juste
là tu as première page
ça tue ça déchire et bien écoute sur ces
premières pages y écrit ta carte n'ont
rien de bien parce que j'ai écris pas
quatre mais ta carte je vais écrire est
dans la pince et on remarquera que ici
depuis le daily mail passe ya une pince
il ya une carte depuis le début l'as de
carreau tu as choisi on retire je prends
la carte
hélas non une carte et une seule la la
sur cette première page de carême il ya
maintenant le dessin d'une d'une carte
pense à une autre carte pana c'est trop
facile mais notre carlita
on n'est pas content et je regarde dans
les yeux tu penses à la carte
ouais c'est très flatteur mais pense à
la carte ces bons beats à jakarta que
vous pensez maintenant dix des treize le
dise de tresses est juste là il ya écrit
10 de 13
juste la nôtre le truc de malade
on va aller plus loin on va aller plus
loin parce que j'aimerais que vous
imaginez que votre carte soit là juste
là dans l'espace j'aimerais que comme
tout à l'heure dans la pince vous savez
elle était plié j'aimerais que vous la
plier en quatre mentalement d'accord et
la regarder dans ma pince qui est là la
carte c'était quoi qu'un peu 19
c'est le diable si j'ouvre la carte ici
on voit qu'il ya une carte quoi toi d
excellents en tournée dans toute la
france m'a guidé
murphy make sure we love qui restent
avec nous héritons à d'exceptionnelles
eric antoine valla